[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله نقلت رويترز عن مصدر في ان
نتنياهو سيعلق على الارجح التعديلات
القضائيه ياتي ذلك بعدما تظاهر الاف
الاسرائيليين في تل ابيب ومدن اخرى
احتجاجا على اقاله رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بن يمينه ياهو وزير الدفاع
على خلفيه ازمه التعديلات القضائيه وتجمع
الالاف امام منزلي نتنياهو مطالبين
باستقالته
كما تجمع الاف المتظاهرين في محيط الكنيست
رفضا للتعديلات القضائيه ويعقد الكنيست
الاجتماعا اليوم وقد استانفت لجنه القضاء
والدستور مداولتها تمهيدا للتصويت على
تعديل قانون لجنه تعيين القضاه وسيشارك
وزير الدفاعيه المقال في النقاش خلال
الاجتماعي لجنه الخليجيه والامن
البرلمانيه بشان التعديلات القضائيه
انها رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي باليمين
نتنياهو مشاورات استمرت حتى صباح اليوم
لمناقشه التداعيات السياسيه لقله وزير
الدفاعي
ومن المتوقع ان يلقي نتنياهو خطابا صباح
اليوم يحدد فيه موقف حكومته من الاستمرار
في التغييرات القضائيه او وقفها ودعا رئيس
الاسرائيلي الى وقف التعديلات القضائيه
على الفور حفاظا على وحده الاسرائيليين
واعلن وزراء
تاييدهم لوقف التعديلات اذا اتخذ نتنياهو
قرارا بهذا السبب
وقد قالت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان
الجيش رفع حاله التاهب ودفع بتعزيزات بعد
فقدان السيطره داخل اسرائيل
ودعا قاده في ائتلاف في نتنياهو الحاكم
للتراجع عن تعديلات قضائيه تحصنه من
المساءله بينما اتهمه زعماء المعارضه
بتجاوز كل الخطوط الحمراء وحذروا من
انهيار الدوله واعلن القنصل الاسرائيلي في
نيويورك استقالته احتجاجا على اقاله وزير
الدفاع
الى ذلك قال متحدث باسم البيت الابيض ان
الولايات المتحده تشعر بقلق بالغ نزال
الاحدث في اسرائيل وبانها تحث القاده
الاسرائيليين على التوصل الى تسويه في
اقرب وقت ممكن من جهته حذر مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي من تاثير الازمه على
الجيش الاسرائيلي
دعت وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه الى عقد
اجتماع استثنائي لمجلس الامن لمناقشه
تصريحات الروسيه بشان نيه موسكو نشره
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا
ووصفت الخارجيه الاوكرانيه الخطوه الروسيه
بالاستفزازيه
وقال متحدث باسم حلف النيتون خطاب روسيا
عن الاسلحه النوويه خطير وغير مسؤول مضيفا
ان الحلفه متيقظ ويراقب الموقف بدوره قلم
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل ان استضافه بيلاروسيا اسلحه
نوويه روسيه تهديد للامن الاوروبي ملوحا
بفرض مزيد من العقوبات
اشكركم على متابعه الموجه
اوقاتكم بكل خير